ترقد تحت هذا الركام احلام قتلت ففي كل
منزل قصص وحكايا دفنت مع ابطالها صغارا
كانوا او كبارا اما الناجون فيلاحقهم
الخوف والرعب وبات العيش بين الجدران
كابوسا يؤرقهم مهند شاب سوري فقد اخويه
تحت الانقاض وعاش مع عائلته لولا اللحظات
الاولى لتارثه ورغم عدم تضرر منزله بات
يخشى العوده اليه لتغدو هذه الخيمه
مستقرهم الاشاعات اللي صارت الضعف
المعلومات اللي عنا الجيولوجيه اللي نحن
ما بنعرف عنها شيء ابائنا واجدادنا مع شو
هاي الفتره اللي صارت فنحن عنا خوف مكبوت
ما عم نفرجيه للاولاد للعيال فانا كيف بدي
اقنع عيلتي انه نروح نسكن وانا في عندي
خوف بداخلي من هذا اللي راح يصير يعزل
مختصون ارتفاع احصائيه الاصابه اضطرابي ما
بعد الصدمه خصوصا بين الاطفال في عموم
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال الى ما عاشه
السكان من خوف وذعر منذ لحظاته الاولى في
ناس تقريبا اصيبوا في هذا المرض وطبعا
النصيحه وهو هذا الاهم هو حسب تعامل الاهل
مع هذا الطفل او هذا الشخص اللي اصيب بهذا
المرض طبعا في عنا خطين خط الاول هو الاخذ
لطبيب نفسه والخط الثاني انه المعالجه
الشخصي بالبيت في ظل غياب مراكز الصحه
النفسيه عن المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
المدمر ومراكز الايواء والمخيمات يؤكد
ناشطون على ضروره العمل الجاد لاخراج
الناجين من هذا الاضطراب الذي اصاب
الكثيرين منهم ما بين مطرقه قصف النظام
والميليشيات الايرانيه على مدار سنوات
وسندان الخوف والمعاناه والنزوح اثر
الزلزال تستمر ماساه السوريين الذين باتت
الخيام اقصى احلامهم رغم ان قماشها لا يقي
برد الشتاء ولا حر الصيف محمد الاشقر
العربيه مدينه ادلب